it's affecting our business already
because of course as 80% of our
passengers are British most of our
revenue is coming in sterling our cost I
in Euro because we are French flag
company so it's affecting our business
because the pound is worth a lot less
against the euro versus last year so
already the first knock is on our profit
profitability and of course the long
term is when the pound is low the Brits
have less purchasing power when they
travel so of course they would they
could be an impact
although 6:16 was a very very good year
and 17 will be not quite such a good
year like wine days fantastic year and
good year and it'll be a bit down but
the move to answer your question the
real straightforward knock is about the
pound and the value of the pound because
of our revenue stream how concerned are
you about the various different types of
brexit I mean what for example would it
mean for you were the UK to leave the EU
without there being a deal in place on
the passenger side you have to have in
mind that Britain is not in Schengen
today so there's already enough control
and they still passport control and out
of that so even in a No Deal scenario
the worst case would be that on top of
then there would be visa application and
that would certainly not be good that's
for sure however there's not there's
already some kind of control I think
there would be more problematic on the
freight side because of course the free
flow of goods would be completely we
would go back in time so the
reintroduction of customs checks the
Channel ports is would be a big concern
to you yeah
for sure it wouldn't be a good thing and
but I hope and I do believe that we will
find in our hope so what sort of
lobbying are you doing in France to try
and persuade the French government to
not to punish the UK for its decision to
leave the EU well what we're doing and
doing is we are trying to through the
chamber of Shipping in the UK through
our Mattel de force which is
equivalent of chamber of shipping my
chairman is the chairman of ARMA
telephone we are just making sure that
we have the right channel to communicate
when the negotiation starts okay they've
started Monday with the early days so
what we want to make sure is that we can
talk on both sides of the channel to
hopefully bring sense if we do feel that
the negotiations become tough because I
do hope that is the economics that will
prevail of a national pride or things
like that so don't so a question we are
today not though being actively we're
just making sure they know that we are
willing to and we are important for both
sides for the trade for the exchange
between the two countries so we are just
ready trade has been somewhat more soft
this year than last is that affecting
the way you're running the business you
still continuing to invest indeed well
it's affecting it's not affecting the
way we run the business affecting our
bottom line for this year however we
remain very confident that things will
sort itself out we've always looked at
in Britain face at the future with
confidence we're not worried when the
company has gone through different
difficult time and we've always managed
to go through and it was the right time
anyhow and we've announced just of light
this new building that will join the
post Muskaan wood the ship will be named
Dion flower and she will be the first
LNG vessel a lot first LNG ferry on the
channel so we are confident and despite
never mind breaks it we move on and we
still look to the future with confidence